[Music]
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith hi I'm Mark Bernard oh [ __ ] man
you can't see us right now you're just
like what happened where's my vision
don't lose shots at my mark in my Matt
Murdock I've been canceled by Netflix II
was a hit by a radioactive isotope no
you were hit with cancellation yeah no
man we couldn't get to the bar to do fat
man beyond live so we figure we had to
rush here to the house do a home show
like an old school talk about this movie
that we love so much man we talked about
spider-man colon into the spider-verse
the least the movie least likely to wind
up being perhaps my favorite movie of
2018 I'm gonna bury the lead
let it out I [ __ ] love this movie now
I had it this this is a year man I
always liked the spider-man who doesn't
like spider-man come on when I was
rooting for him this movie made me love
spider-man on a Batman type lovely oh my
god just shows you any character in the
right hands man could be a transform of
experience I love this movie we're gonna
deep on it of course but I've already
said my my I've already I couldn't
couldn't hold back I had to get it out
there my top come once so that I could
work it up now and [ __ ] turn a turn
we'll take our time yes where is this
for me do your first Nutting maybe you
do it I could not have foreseen a year
in which not only would we get to giant
studio films
with black superhero leads but that the
one of them that is my favorite movie of
the year was not black panther ah yes
you know I always forget that that was
[ __ ] February I now this this year
this is second year of all years is
impact and that seems like a lifetime
ago it said particularly because we've
had Avengers infinity war because we met
chala
and T'Challa and then he [ __ ] baby
well happened in one year
that's so [ __ ] that I know yeah I I
saw that I remember feeling I saw the
trailer mmm I think when he came out
over the summer and I didn't know what
to expect because I died despite my long
relationship with Miles Morales I've
never actually read any of the mouths
Morales comic books but um why do you
have a long row because you wrote about
them and because Donald Glover yeah I
wrote that story for io9 in 2010 but I
think this was wondering why Spiderman
had to be a white guy and and then in
the comments for that story somebody
suggested Donald Glover and then no the
Glover gets wind of it and he's out
there like we're in spider-man jammies
on community and he sort of embraces it
and resists it because there were death
threats as I understand I mean I got
like three or four just for writing an
article wondering why he had to be a
white guy seriously yeah people were
just like you should [ __ ] die for
saying yeah it's like because Stan wrote
it that way because that's the way it's
supposed to be because it's always been
that way and if you've got a problem
with that I'm sure there's a you know
you probably commuting in Manhattan
somewhere like I don't know maybe we'll
see each other on the street I can't be
sure that is so [ __ ] right man if you
say so but Glover got it far worse I
feel like I don't know there's any
character I'm that protective of where
I'm like where I'd even raise my voice
to somebody let alone be like you might
die at my head suggesting that it be
something other than what I know it to
be yeah like they weren't they were
motivated in a way there's like the
cat's it didn't like the lady
Ghostbusters movie right or like you
know there's an Asian person in Star
Wars I don't understand
maybe this lady should die or be privy
to any number of awful sexual things
[ __ ] changes kids like just fine here
but the beautiful thing is like that
thing that you love it's never going
away if you love the store if you love
fearful symmetry that features a white
spider-man fighting you know
craven the white hunter and stuff like
that that ain't gonna way you'll always
have that and it hasn't been obliterated
from history or something like that
pulped every copy of it they haven't
pulled it down like a statue that you
never gave a [ __ ] about before like this
it's literally it's always gonna be
there
now there's just one more version and in
and I'm Craig me from wrong mark I
believe the premise of that movie is
there are many spiders really nobody can
wear the mask and he can be a non-white
and he can be a boy and he can be a girl
and it can be a big that's what makes me
[ __ ] crazy like all before this movies
Peter porker spider-ham existed so
somebody once said hey man you know
you're white god Peter Parker he's a pig
now and nobody threatened anybody's life
over that nope but somebody gon like
would it be interesting if this kid was
black I will cut you yeah it's like
there was a stretch there in the comics
where Thor was a frog yeah it was like
did you have a problem with that no he's
a frog it's cool that could happen
because man Jack wrote it down what
about what if he was a black frog [ __ ]
yeah and we're talking about the god of
thunder shut up yeah and so Donna Glover
sort of embraced it and then but Brian
Michael Bendis and I'm also caught wind
of it and said hey you know what you're
right there is no reason why Spiderman
couldn't be a black guy in fact I have
two adopted black children like wouldn't
be great if they had a spider-man for
them and so he wrote invented Miles
Morales you know so that came after your
article that came after the article like
in all kind of spins out of the earth as
I sat there watching the moon so weird I
said in front of you we talked and I
know we've talked about this but as I
said they're watching the movie I said
they're gone like they were really ahead
of the curve with Miles Morales about
thirty years too late but it's still
ahead of like the curve so much so that
like he was perfectly poised to be the
lead of this movie yep and I literally
said to myself I was like wonder how
this all got started
have to look it up wow that's [ __ ] up
and so you never read the books I never
really read the books like I it came
about in a time when like my bandwidth
was very small and I was either like
making [ __ ] or working or whatever it
was but my Marvel readership dropped off
in a big bad way and so I never like I
knew a little bit about what Mouse was
and and and his world but I was never a
reader of that book so I came to this
with a knowledge of the character but no
knowledge whatsoever of what happens to
that character though and it was it was
kind of glorious and I just I remember
just seeing that first trailer and just
a look of it just blew me away
that's when I first suck me and I was
like wow this looks really good yeah
like I was I was talking to a friend of
the show Zach's tens oh yes who who said
I feel like I've seen something new I
agree and it's been a long time since
I've seen something new I agree and it's
this this weird merging of like you know
3d animation and 2d panel structure and
dialogue boxes and thought balloons and
all of these things well they had my
heart from that second they released a
clip of Peter Parker teaching Miles
Morales to swing and so you know he's
going now whip it out and release the
whip and release and on screen every
time they thrip it says flip yeah and I
was like wow somebody [ __ ] loves this
[ __ ] like this ain't a soulless cash
grab no this is son this was made with
true affection
there's sequences that especially early
on which are like out of register yeah a
little bit blurry yes because that's how
comics used to be when the printing
presses were not [ __ ] in calibrated
the right way and things were always a
little off
right well blurry the the dots the
colored dots didn't match up that so the
Zipit own feel was always a little like
ad hoc and and just improvised but it
this feels like a handmade movie yeah by
people who really really really love the
capacity to what you could do you
couldn't make this movie ten years ago
they also it seems like it's a movie
that's made by people who grew up
ingesting this [ __ ] the same way I did
mm-hmm
through a comic book yeah
movie opens with the comic code seal of
approval you know with a thundering both
as it hideous green and right then and
there I was like this is special like
we're amongst friends here yeah it takes
you into the world of spider-man a
familiar spider-man is the first one we
kind of meet right yeah we and and he
voiced by Chris Pine and one of my
favorite performances of the year yeah
he's really great real I didn't know
until the end the movie was him but like
this is the one that you know you think
of when you think of the comics and you
think of the TV show and you the cartoon
you think of classic Spiderman he was
always had the right thing to say legit
good lines funny delivery tired you know
like not tired like this [ __ ] started
but like exhausted because he's fighting
he called him gobby Green Goblin through
pumpkin bombs Green Goblin was this
oversized mutant version of the Green
Goblin but still everything about it was
familiar and the [ __ ] like there's
you know there's only one Spider Man and
you're looking at him in the eye awakes
and stuff all of it was like pitch
perfect yeah and they spoilers wearing
spoil the [ __ ] out of this movie oh yes
I mean you should go see it but I hope
you've already seen it and if you
haven't turned this off go see it
because now we're gonna get rare easily
they kill that spider-man real quick all
[ __ ] fast and they kill him after
this gorgeous [ __ ] sequence where the
collider is launched and and this
sequence and the character himself the
character that I walked away loved and
like you know in the in this movie was
full of Revelations for me but kingpin
was fantastic and you know we've had a
fantastic kingpin with Vincent D'Onofrio
yeah and the fog and daredevil show and
stuff but their rendition of kingpin
looks like the one that bill syncovich
did for daredevil love and war this
gigantis gargantuan non human being that
you know with the head right in the
middle it it looks like that's they
pulled them from the pages of
and some of the graphics as well the
supercollider sequence looks like a
Bilson cabbage painting yeah they they
even I think there's some montage when I
think they're doing the the the kingpin
various universes version yes there's
like covers from like Electress yes yes
they just pull out just give you this in
cabbage they yeah this is where we took
it from oh that right then and there I
was like so good you chose wisely and
and that's you know of [ __ ] superhero
stories only as good as strong as the
villain and they give you a strong
villain who's villainous and you know
criminal mmm-hmm this is my [ __ ]
shoots people and [ __ ] and kills
spider-man like with his own bare
[ __ ] hands and [ __ ] like that and
then sets up a [ __ ] funeral for
spider-man where he honors the death of
Spider invites Mary Jane to come and
speak of the funeral I mean heartless
[ __ ] like truly villainous [ __ ]
and at the heart of the story is an
emotional pursuit like even says like
some things ain't about the money
spider-man and Liev Schreiber is [ __ ]
genius as the kingpin he sounds so New
York III it I don't know maybe it's me
but it looks like their rendition of
kingpin almost scenes like Trump without
the hair and he sounds very New York and
and like all of it I don't know if they
were going for but maybe it would
suggest maybe I read something into it
but it's not if you if you're sitting
there going oh I don't like political
move this isn't the same political eye
that might be my takeaway ya know but
like a big sort of cartoonish buffoon
he's got his name on his own building
who talks in and out sighs New York
accent it's not a lot to look this
you're not like string theory metal hat
I don't think a big controversial and I
you know I'm sure he could go back in
the roots of the character and see some
DNA there particularly in the 80s
version of it or something but yeah it's
but he's there's a like a in underneath
the darkness there is this soul this
connection there's a human reason why
yeah he's putting the world in jeopardy
and it's a reason anybody can understand
oh my god I will die
mm-hmm where I was just like look I love
this [ __ ] so I'll take it he's doing it
for the money I'll take it cuz he just
wants to destroy New York or spider-man
like I'll take any [ __ ] reason but
they gave you an emotional reason where
it's just like he's trying to get his
wife and kid back
yeah he's opening up the multiverse so
that he can steal breathtaking nice I've
almost found a cry just thinking about
that is I I wonder how they felt when
they hit that story be where they were
just like the reason Fisk is doing this
is because he wants to get his wife and
kid back who he's responds quasi
responsible for their death you learned
in flashback he's fighting spider-man
and then Vanessa and and his son Richard
come in and see him and see him who for
who he is because he's always presenting
he's got a secret identity as well
presents as Wilson Fisk
to his family presents his kingpin to
the underworld so they see him for what
he is and they you know run away and get
in a car and they're getting into a car
accident so he he has this real reason
for hating [ __ ] spider-man and almost
not justifiable but like when the movie
opens with like the [ __ ] death of
spider-man at the hands of kingpin and
you know it's a spider-verse movie hey
there's more we've already met Miles
Morales it had miles as watch we know
he's about to be spider-man in amenities
and you know he's he's got the powers
but he doesn't do it right he gets bit
even before they before them but I mean
it's it they created a one of the best
villains and a Marvel anything ever
he'd go shoulder to shoulder with Thanos
yeah and he's a [ __ ] cartoon you know
what I'm saying like at the end of the
day his his performance is so [ __ ]
human hats off to like the animators
hats off to the [ __ ] performance hats
off to the writers yeah then and along
those lines the Prowler is
an excellent [ __ ] villain - oh he's
great it broke my heart
what a heartbreakingly great story so
much so that Nic Cage is spider-man
Norah's like it's pretty hard secret
origin it's a pretty hardcore but it's
also like I I didn't see it coming but I
totally should have seen it coming but
you knew right like I knew those
characters are related in the comics I I
didn't know about I don't know if they
did that in the comic I don't know they
died either but once he died because
again it's it's you know Prowler is is
kingpins henchman sort of right-hand man
and overall mr. fix-it dude who who
wants one smiles Mikasa to muscle
costume muscle once Miles Morales as
spider-man you know sort of emerges on
the scene in his like ill-fitting suit
and he's got you know old fat Peter
Parker by his side
proudly gets turned on to this kid
anything before that like like when
spider-man is killed miles is there
miles we should go back to the beginning
we're jumping all over the place
miles miles is a mixed-race kid from
yeah I'm from Brooklyn is a wonderful
moment where they him and his uncle are
under alchemax and he's like such a New
York kid thing I mean and and the entire
vibe of this movie was so New York it's
so New York and it's so specifically
like black New York I think that music
is all hip-hop like you know once like
they're going under the tunnels and
suddenly like b.i.g like hypnotized when
I start tagging their mix like is is
well they play his uncle his uncle's
course old with him so the mix on the
tape and it's a big old boom box we
cassette is our the music we grew up and
just [ __ ] biggie it's it's it's it's
Apache it's awesome and and and so whens
beautiful sequence it's a beautiful
sequence and even the beginning of the
movie might one of my favorite parts
happens right off the top where they say
okay there's some things you might
recognize like there's some things that
you know before this happened and it's
you know spider-man stopping the train
you know with all of that stuff these
the many origins that they do for like
okay let's tell the story one more time
my name is Peter Parker I was bitten by
a radioactive spider for the last ten
years I've been the one
only spiderman and then they kind of
walked through the career right this is
a device they used to like is that the
start of every chapter when a new
character is introduced and miles
doesn't really get one until very end
yeah he gets his moment of truth and
then I thought that was a wonderful
device because they would slap the comic
cover down and to be like this is the
story and then like spider-gwen tells
her story and and spiderman noir tells
his story and stuff but when you finally
get to the moment where miles earns his
cover and it's slaps down you're in
tears the whole [ __ ] movie I was in
tears very emotional father-son stuff is
really wonderful
yeah and they and they do this family
stuff but I only thought about after the
fact but Miles Morales his name is Miles
Morales his mother I don't remember what
her name in the movie but she speaks to
him in Spanish in English kind of
interchangeably he only speaks back to
her in English and his father his last
name is Nam Morales he's just his name
again I can't remember I should probably
do this research but it's less seems
like Jones or something and so they set
up this family in which you've got a
father who is not miles as natural
father but that love that they share the
bond that they have is as deep and as
rich as if they were blood and it's not
they're not related the last names are
different like I don't think miles is
that guy's son Aaron is it Aaron Rodgers
could be this is the name of the Fowler
yeah so they probably had wood yeah
Fowler's last name is not Aaron Morales
arriver
you know and the daddy was a cop
sleazebag says Jones or something on it
but just that relationship that they
don't even talk about they don't even
sort of glance on but it's deep and it's
rich and it's and it feels valid and you
know it's it's what a modern family
looks like which is hey maybe you know
this is a different kid from a different
father but this is the new family unit
and the love is there and it's deep and
they and it doesn't have the tension
that you might expect from this kind of
story well no it's adoptive dad or
whatever mom got remarried and this is
new dance stepdad
and he doesn't call them like bill in
the way that a movie will always do it's
like oh hey Bill you can call me Dad
sure bill this is just a family and it's
wonderful it's weird and processed it I
hadn't thought like but you're right
never be his mom's last name yeah his
dad's name is not it's not officer
Morales no wonder what the story is
there yeah I'm not sure and and and the
fact that they don't even really comment
on it kind of a nice he's kind of a nice
thing like that does vamoose don't so
you don't got to be the kids as blood to
be like hey man you should make more of
your life because you got a spark like
that's just yeah it's just it's rental
thing and and and especially because so
much of this movie does hinge on family
like the improvised family of the spider
people yes who are all bonded by tragedy
the fact that you know some of the
turning points in this movie are just
based entirely upon the bonds of family
you know when his uncle Aaron who
spoiler again is the Prowler dies like
it broke my heart and then I realized I
should have known this because every
spider-man leaves is an uncle that's the
origin story oh [ __ ] like they've all
got to lose an uncle that's how you make
a spider-man right and it's like the
fact that I didn't see that coming
it was like oh man that's genius I
should have seen it but didn't Aaron
Davis Darren hmm let's talk about all
right so we establish that he's the kind
of Leslie are gonna look now where as
Jefferson remarried that's the the
ultimate incarnation of prowler this is
from the Wikipedia the ultimate has in
the ultimate universe the incarnation of
Prowler is Aaron Davis the uncle of
spider-man Miles Morales and the brother
of Jeff Davis Jefferson Davis whereas
Jefferson reformed by marrying Rio
Morales Aaron never came around and
becomes the Prowler cat burglar he
breaks into the abandoned Oscorp lab to
steal a small red box and other rare
items from a safe but oscorp's
genetically altered spider crawled into
his duffel bag
later miles visits his apartment and
he's bitten by the spider I remember
that like so his origin the origin in
the movie is better yeah it's adjusted
it just happens to be a spider who's
there it's not and thereunder alchemax
and it's not Oscorp and stuff like that
after miles passes out regains
consciousness Jefferson forbids Aaron
spend time with Miles on account of his
criminal life during a visit to Mexico
City Aaron fights off the Mexican crime
boss scorpion when his deal with
scorpion goes bad he's detained by the
authorities returning to New York
Prowler interrogate stinker about Norman
Osborn of Oscorp spider-man ultimately
gets into a fight with air and that
results in Aaron's gauntlets exploding
killing him but not before accusing his
nephew of being just like him a year
later spider-man discovers that Aaron
was hired to break into Oscorp I feel
like Roxanna was revealed to be a
criminal acquaintance of Turk Barrett
and blah blah blah blah
so when Miles decides to sever that or
the miles initially convinced initially
convince his boss to assist in defeating
scorpion however spider-man comes to
realize his uncle's exploitation when
miles decides to sever their
relationship Aaron threatens to tell
Jefferson and Rio of his nephews secret
identity
spider-man ultimately gets into a fight
with their and that results in Aaron's
gauntlets exploding I like what they did
in the movie much much more it's cleaner
yeah and it also boy I didn't see it
mmm the way you said it but you're
absolutely right you gotta lose an uncle
yeah although penny Parker lost her dad
but it's like yeah that's that's way
smarter yeah and have kingpin do it and
I can have it and have it be a choice
like Aaron chooses Prowler chooses not
did you know there's an amazing moment
where you're like what is he doing yeah
when he pulled his mask over his face
again I was like oh this is cold it's
going dark
yeah like spider-man those gloves are
gonna power up so anyway they introduce
you to Miles Morales in his world and
he's on his way over to like a boarding
school there you know the vision Academy
we're gonna sleep there and she had like
you'd sleep there for a week and then
get
go back home with his folks in his world
I guess other kids would go there and
just [ __ ] stay there and stay but he
don't want to be there he'd rather be at
like Brooklyn middle or whatever the
[ __ ] standard school yeah which is
weird like I was trying to figure out
for myself sort of the what is the need
that the movie answers in in Miles
Morales you know because when you think
about sort of mythic story when you
think about any story telling this this
the the story of a movie character they
serve a moving protagonist is over the
course of that movie the characters
should have some need that he needs to
have filled you know like Luke Skywalker
his need is to go off and join the
[ __ ] the Rebel Alliance his need is
to get off that rock his need is to find
himself a place in the larger world and
it establishes that with him looking off
at two sunsets it says I was supposed to
go off through the Academy this year's
like well you'll go next year you know
we need you here Luke and so the movie
answers that need the movie puts him in
the middle of you know intergalactic
intrigue and it [ __ ] blows up the
Death Star like what is miles is need
and is it to be exceptional and he's not
or is it to understand and embrace the
fact that he is exceptional and I think
it's probably the second one because
he's pushing it away at the beginning I
don't want to go to this fancy Academy I
just want to go to school with my
friends like what you're smarter than
man yeah but I just want to I don't want
to embrace the fact that I am special
and so he pushes it away until he
embraces it and that's why you can't
control his [ __ ] the venom sting and
he can't control his invisibility
because he's not embracing the fact that
he is actually and he was he had a spark
even before he got bit by a spider
interesting I think that there's a
writer later
I just thought they're gone like spider
movie could cry now boohoo well it was
also helpful that we you know at least I
saw this we saw this on the heels of a
different superhero movie which we'll
talk about in a later episode true this
but but drawing the comparisons between
the two and trying to figure out for
myself why one works and one at one
doesn't was trying to diagnose the urin
what does he need and yeah Peter needs
Peter miles needs to realize that he's
special you know Peter as we discover in
the movie also has is
need and into you know admit that you
were wrong admit that you don't know
everything and admit that but if you can
apologize you know to Mary Jane then
maybe you can have a chance at life
right and yeah admit that you might not
be the hero that you think you are
miles goes to school but he don't like
being at school and his dad wants him to
be better and it's really touching stuff
with his dad driving to school you've
all seen in the trailer it's funny too
this movie is legit funny you will laugh
out loud but it'll make you feel and
make you laugh this is everything a
[ __ ] movie should be boy its escapism
cuz this [ __ ] could never happen in real
life none of it I'm sorry yes I know
there are people out there like yeah you
know and and you yeah so and if
somebody's working on a super collider
there to like break through the
multiverse like I'll eat my hat but I
doubt none of this is [ __ ] true this
is pure fantasy and it's wonderful
fantasy that makes you somehow want to
be a better person when it's all even
though it's cants you can't possibly see
yourself up there but you can its point
anyone can wear the mask they literally
tell you at the end of the movie so I
don't know why it works but [ __ ] it's
magic I mean because I think that that
you know like we talked about with
Kington the reasons why he does what he
does are rooted in very real human sort
of wants and desires and I want my
family back and it's my fault that
they're gone and I'm gonna fix it by any
means necessary if I have to ruin the
world to do it I'm gonna get those two
people back in my life you know I mean
miles again wants to need to embrace who
he is where we're at our best when we
admit who we are and everything else in
our lives suffers if we can't admit to
who we are our relationship with our
parents or than show with our friends
you know our relationship to the girl
that we got a crush on like all of those
things begin to come into focus as long
as you can be the person that you're
supposed to be and embrace your destiny
and don't be afraid of it like that's
the the whole point of that [ __ ]
anybody can wear the mask
it fits of the suit always fits
eventually you know I mean I wasn't
ready and I was ready I'm like well I'm
sure he's gonna be in herself
and I wasn't ready for how perfect that
cameo was miles likes to hang out with
his uncle Aaron and so he kind of drops
out of school for the day where he's
supposed to stay like all the time
overnight he's supposed to be doing an
essay on great expectations not the book
but I mean like of his life from
whatever the [ __ ] and so him and his
uncle hang out and he's got the cool
uncle and they got a fun little
relationship or his uncle's trying to
like teach him the shoulder move mm-hmm
just walk up to a girl go hey and then
his uh miles is a bit of a tagger likes
to tag like name tags literally slap him
all over town
so his uncle's like I got a place let's
go and they it was really sweet little I
mean again I knew he was the Prowler
they get to like this fence the
character movements [ __ ] incredible
on the Prowler character his run as he
chases spider-man is one of the most
terrifying [ __ ] images you'll see
this year it's relentless and the score
back in it like when it's just as scary
it's yeah [ __ ] scary look man if I
was a kid watching that movie that would
haunt my dreams so they show him hop in
this [ __ ] fence like park horn and
yet Jackie Channing is way over the
fence and it's like beautiful like and
and you're just as gobsmacked is like
miles who's never seen his uncle in
quite that capacity but if you know the
comics you're like oh of course he's
prowlers so they get on to the over the
other side of this fence and there's a
space where they're just tagged and they
put on this old school beatboxing and
start painting miles paints there's no
expectations mural and you know his
uncle's kind of like like surrogate dad
he looks up to him more than it looks up
to his cop dad he's [ __ ] obi-wan
Kenobi for this kid it's it's the like
here's here's the one here's a person
who's gonna teach me how I can live my
life he enjoys it he has fun with it he
does what he wants to do he goes where
he wants to go
where his dad is all about rules his
uncle is all about fun and if you know
where it's going and even if you don't
if you don't it's a [ __ ] even more
wicked rat I'd imagine yeah you have no
idea that the Heartbreakers coming nope
didn't even see it coming
so they got put there under alchemax
tagging in Spider 42 drops down and
there's a great montage of them painting
with great [ __ ] hip hop old school
hip hop where the spider is you know
ever about to mmm be where he needs him
the audience knows it's got to be the
kid it's got to be Miles like we're
gonna happen yeah and and it works at in
a fun way all the way up till the end
when miles is taking a little selfie or
done selfies take a snapshot of his
artwork and then the spider crawls on
his hand and you know fangs do multi
panels and stuff they really make use of
the comic book language not overuse
where you're like you know [ __ ] I get it
perfect use of it yeah we're a dommage
it never feels like they're hitting you
over the head with it and they and they
use it in ways that enhance the
emotionality of it like there's there's
you know the sequence when he's running
away from coz right after that scene he
goes in to see spider-man get killed by
a kingpin and he gets the first he goes
oh no after that he goes did he go home
for he goes home and that's where he
[ __ ] gets taller remember and then he
goes into school and seized Wanda again
and his hand gets stuck in her hair and
then they've got to cut her hair because
his fingers start sticking to everything
and then he gets chased around school by
the security guy he's live he'll never
find me here and he's like I'm picking
wrong desk he's sticking to the wall he
winds up walking out he is it great the
birds are stuck to his hand it's a
fantastic comedic bit something you
could never do in the real world if you
did it would take a long time but it
just sells because of the the media were
in the medium were in the animation and
because we all know how spider-man six
to [ __ ] walls yeah
really wonderful sight gag and then he
falls out the windows
cool makin like he's running away and
and you can see that it breaks into
panels and these panels has like a
little thought balloon or that the
narration balloons they what the hell is
happening to me and it just it's it's
this perfect seamless melding of vision
it was a fantastic score - yeah like it
was a real great what the [ __ ] is going
on with me and because his roommate is
in the comics Myles like sees these you
know he winds up with a issue of
spider-man hoes face and sees the exact
thing happening to a character named
Billy in the comics in their world
everyone knows about spider-man they
just don't know who he is right and
there's lots of spider-man merch like as
the spider-man told us you know as you
saw in the trailer he's like there's
this there's this there's I have a great
TV theme song Christmas album all these
shinning and a pretty okay ice pop did
you hear today that they're releasing
the Christmas album so smart such a
granddaddy I mean here we are on the
cusp of Christmas Chris Pine singing
tune have a spidey Christmas so good so
he you know he's he's a known quantity
in this world so miles sees in the
comics the character going through what
he's going through and then sees him get
bit by the spider and he's like oh my
god no I just get bit by a normal spider
and so he's like I got to go back and
find the spider so it goes back to
alchemax and looking for the spider
which is the only like narrative part of
the device for your life would you look
for the spider but you got to get him
back to alchemax right it's a clue trail
yeah and it doesn't even last for that
long because the minute he gets back
Talcott makes the spider senses go off
for the first time and blam yes a giant
spider-man fight with this oversized
gargantuan Green Goblin going on while
kingpin is watching you know as in this
gigantic super collider room and
spider-man is breathtakingly spider-man
the most spider-man oh my god like the
swing up to the roof and the crawl and
he punches and he goes nope find the
other panel [ __ ] and tries to get the
key in just to deactivate it in the nick
of time and stuff the confidence and yet
at the same time the
phal ability that makes him wonderful
that be reminding me that moment in
Avengers age of Ultron where Tony Stark
is in that sokovia castle man he's like
please be a secret door please be so you
can do it easy for door but he gets you
know attacked by Prowler takes him down
and he's is real great because he's like
Prowler come on man like it's not even
like oh my god the Prowler yeah they
killed by the prowl mildly irritated by
the Prowler interrupting and his ability
to spider-man themselves out of the
situation and that's when he faces a
kingpin and the kingpins like you're
gonna love the light show and turns on
the super collider and green Goblin's
forcing spider-man's face into the
stream that's being created that's
essentially like the multiverse opening
up a tear into the multiverse and stuff
or you're kind of seeing multiple
versions and they break and shatter and
so some of those characters some of
those Spider Men wind up coming to this
world that the movies taking place in
right and it's all like Kirby crackle
and and just weird sometimes like Andy
Warhol yeah
Crowley mystic Kevin so yeah I can touch
to it and you know of kingpins like you
know no get him out of there shut it
down and so they shut it David blows the
[ __ ] up Green Goblin is killed meanwhile
Peter miles is there miles went back to
alchemax and so he's seen while this
happened and at one point he falls and
spider-man swinging while he's fighting
Green Goblin but he hears it like you
see the spider senses because they draw
all over this [ __ ] like the
lines and then he quick spins around
because that's he spider-man he's gonna
save the [ __ ] person who's in
jeopardy and he catches miles and puts
him like you know it's a safe bridge of
some sort and I got both they both have
a spider sense thing that goes off I
knows I was like wait you're like me yes
so he recognizes him and right away he's
like you know I can show you the ropes
you
I can teach you how to be spider-man in
mouths like oh my god yes because I just
got to take care of this you know one
thing for me I guess stop this one thing
from natori in the world but just stay
here and that's when he does the
breathtaking [ __ ] swings where miles
is watching this and you're like you
know I'm gonna cry by the end of the
movie spoilers miles gets to do the
exact same thing the same [ __ ] swing
then he watched spider-man do to get to
the top the [ __ ] super collider he
finally gets to do but he watches
spider-man and while this fights going
on he's like I should help him and he's
like Who am I kidding I can't [ __ ]
help him and so he talks himself out of
it so whole thing blows up goblins
killed
spider-man is like blown to [ __ ] it
looks like hell miles goes over to talk
to him so Peter and miles get to have a
conversation and he it's a it's so
[ __ ] good dude when he's like when
spider-man is telling him he's like you
got up he goes where the mask he's going
you have to hide your identity he goes
everyone's in his pocket like it's so
[ __ ] good you're like that's the
rationale like of course you would wear
a [ __ ] mask because kingpin owns
everybody he's like you wear the mask to
protect yourself and you protect your
family because everybody's in his pocket
you don't know who to trust like there's
the slight edge of paranoia which makes
[ __ ] sense of like he's trying to
communicate as quickly as he can to the
kid this is the [ __ ] you need to
understand to be spider-man in his last
in his dying words yes
telling his but he keeps telling he's
like oh don't worry kid I'm not gonna
that's a big part of it like spider-man
even in his narration he's they keep
shouting I'm getting the [ __ ] [ __ ]
knocked down and we get sued but at the
end of the day I always get up and you
know be they [ __ ] him show him getting
up he's like cuz I'm spider-man so he
tells miles he's like I'm gonna you know
I'm gonna get up I just need a minute I
always get up don't worry about it but
like then you hear kingpin coming with
tombstone yeah that's right a character
you never [ __ ] say this maybe they
like the the cinematic debut mixed media
debut of [ __ ] of Tombstone as
kingpins muscle and he looks [ __ ]
ferocious and Groot
gruesome and so you hear kingpins coming
so Peter Parker is like here take this
key you know you got to get it up and to
plug it into the hole up there and you
press the button he's like if you don't
do that he's gonna destroy it all
everything you know everybody you know
like it's so [ __ ] intense yeah and
he's like promise me you could do this
promise me and the kid this is looking
at him he's like guy promise and he's
like go get out of here some miles runs
and kingpin comes over and spider-man
has just quit bein up you know where
he's I spiked kingpins like I'd say
spider-man I'd say it was nice to see
you again but it's not and he's like
King he don't you want to eat he's gonna
tombstone is gonna [ __ ] shoot him and
KN spider-man goes don't you want to
know what I saw him there and kingpin
stops tombstone because he wants to know
what spider-man saw on the stream it's
heartbreaking you don't even if you I'm
gonna cry because I know the story so I
know what this means but when it
happened the first time I was like what
the [ __ ] he goes it's not gonna work
they're gone
and [ __ ] kingpin like explodes and
rage and there's like a panel or two of
like this gruesome grotesque version of
him with rage and fire me I'm like and
then he brings his fists down he [ __ ]
kills Peter Parker like at the start of
the [ __ ] movie while Miles Morales is
looking on survived then and there
you're like what the where are we in the
story like because I saw the trailer
he's swinging with a beautiful beautiful
girl yeah like what's going and then you
realize oh wait this is a multiverse
story so maybe that's uh department like
you're trying to get ahead of it cuz
you've seen the trailer how wonderful it
would have been to not ever see in the
trailer and just be going in you know
completely blind I long for the days
where that's possible it happened so
rarely that that it's possible to even
just no part of the problem though like
think you know I can turn away but I'm
like I want to see everything they put a
trailer up I'll watch it they show me
but watch it oh my god I'll watch the
same clip a thousand times I know it's
bad for me but I'll do it anyway some
miles is at that point he sees
spider-man get killed and he's like that
they you know he's trying to leave and
he make some noise and kingpin goes King
good looks up and literally goes kill
that guy he's so good masculine it's
just so [ __ ] dark and [ __ ] this is a
movie that doesn't give a [ __ ] that
there's a boy running around Halloween
costume they will try to [ __ ] what's in
his uncle and to go with totally so he
goes on the run and the Prowler goes
after miles and he it's a pretty
ferocious [ __ ] chase like he chases
him through the sewers out of the bottom
of Malcolm X and and the way they depict
him running like it's it's kind of real
and it would you'd like if somebody was
running at you like that and you would
run twice as fast or you would try
because you were like if they catch me
they're gonna hurt me it's over its
predatory yeah I like this scene I do
die at the hands of all of these people
yeah this is not gonna be a conversation
if he catches me so he's running from
the prowler and we don't know the
backstory of the Prowler yet we don't
know their connection is an audience
unless you know the comics and he gets
away from him by way of the invisibility
is out the first time it keeps him yeah
so I didn't know if that was a part of
his that spider-man Miles Morales
spider-man can go invisible I don't know
if that's something that created for the
movie the movie if they Dan great it's
fantastic and as is the venom punch and
that feels like it was taken from like
spider-man 2099 I don't know who makes
an appearance in the end credits yes but
it's creating yeah pointing as Oscar
Isaacs is doing the voice which is of
Miguel I was looking at the credits
going who's Oscar Isaacson this and then
all of a sudden the last scene played
and I'm like that's Oscar Isaac this
movie is so good they threw away Oscar
Isaac post [ __ ] credits team that's
how confident these people work so he
disappears in the Prowler loses track of
them and stuff and then miles is like
doesn't know what to do
and he tries to you know become
spider-man he goes to the top of the
building and tries to jump off and then
can't goes back down it was into a
shorter building that [ __ ] and so he's
in his pursuit of trying to be
spider-man he breaks the key the goober
know he this later called the key that
spider-man gave him so he goes to the
Peter Parker's grave and meanwhile they
show like New York like the news hits
the world that Peter Parker was is dead
and when kingpin pulls off his mask at
one point before it kills him and it's a
blonde Peter Parker right so right away
I'm not in Kansas and and also alright
you can kill him cuz not any Peter
Parker but by the end of the movie
you're like that was Peter Parker yeah
like there's somebody was like tried to
say online you know schlubby Peter
Parker is the real Peter Parker but it's
like you missed the [ __ ] point of
that movie the entire blame if you're
trying to make the one true spider-man
like they're all valid and [ __ ] like
that
so he's at the he at one point sees the
funeral where Mary Jane is speaking and
the audience or a bunch of people
wearing [ __ ] masks and some of them
weren't spider-man masks and stuff I
think that's when he goes and gets his
man that's when he's yeah he's he did
worse with a funeral and well he says
kingpin is throwing it cuz he sees that
on the news and so he goes to get a mask
and a costume because Peter said
spider-man I said like you got a hide
you always ask and he goes to a costume
shop and who sells in the costume with
[ __ ] Stan himself Stan Lee and Stan
says you know he was a friend of mine
you know or son was in the line where I
knew him you know I think it was he was
a friend and we were friends you know I
think that's what he said which you know
even now just wants to make me [ __ ]
well up like it's to have it's so close
to Stan leavin period and to have him
say you know we were friends you know
they were [ __ ] friends Stan's entire
mythology
was spun on the back of spider-man hmm
everything Stan is today was connected
to the spider-man has Stan's DNA in him
and vice-versa so that cameo and you
know it ends with like you know Stan
saying as Mark said what's the line he
goes he's okay the suit always fits
eventually yeah son you'll get there he
smiles and there's a sign behind him
that says no return such a classic kind
of like that's very Stan yeah yeah hit
me hit me
I'm trying to remember if it hit me as
hard as it did at the end of Rob one
where you see Leia right and I think
that came out like a month after Carrie
had passed away and just that like that
that little reminder you didn't expect
that you were going to get of somebody
who meant that much to this world
throughout having been gone then I think
I think this was this was a little bit
hard because they it's so recent and
it's Stan yeah
Stan playing Stan and it's like probably
one of the most meaningful cameos yeah
in terms of like oh my God look at him
interacting with the next generation of
the character created and telling him
selling him a spider-man suit like you
and all got to be you know a
psychiatrist or a deep thinker or Martin
Bernard a great writer to see the
symbolism in Stanley handing Miles
Morales his suit and that suit is a
spider-man suit and telling him that
everyone grows into the suit and yeah
it's the mental past oh my god it's
[ __ ] beautiful so I don't care who
you are you're [ __ ] getting choked up
moment the movie theater if not you know
rollin tears like I did so then he goes
to the funeral and like you know that's
where she says well I don't know if it's
reversed where he goes to the funeral
first and she says we're all spider-man
and because he's like at the end he's
like I'm you know I'm I got it because
she's a mary jane says you know it's
it's up to you you're spider-man now
and the entire crowd is wearing
Spiderman cops yeah miles is like I'm
spider-man now and the guy leans over
next to his environment mask oh I think
it was a metaphor that's when I think
miles goes up to the rooftop and starts
trying it out and stuff and then he goes
to Peter Parker's grave because the key
is broken right and there's it's covered
with balloons and gifts and like place
the key is like a totem of remembrance
I'd be like I'm sorry I can't do it
couldn't do it and then somebody comes
up behind him and they kind of play it
like it might be a prowler
but it's slubby Peter Parker and he goes
touch the kid and the kids venom punch
kicks in and blows Peter Parker away
while Peter [ __ ] flips at him and
stuff and then miles looks them is like
you're oh my god you're like me but wait
what happened he's loved me and he's
doesn't have blonde hair and the cops
show up like released that dead body kid
what are you doing with the dead body so
if there's a chase where he's got to
carry Peters body through he's stronger
now cuz he's been bitten by the
radioactive sprite but it's very weekend
at Bernie's the amount of damage that
gets done to schlubby beater bar Peter
wakes up just in time to see the Peter
Parker grave coming right at his face
they swing through traffic they're
attached to a subway at overhead train
that's like taking them through the city
and whatnot who's fun sight-gags and
then eventually Peter wakes up and miles
room bedroom yeah just don't attach to
the [ __ ] punching bag mm-hmm and so
you know he's like who are you what's
going on and you get the first version
of alright let's do this one last time
my name is Peter be Parker and he tells
you the story you know for the last I
was bitten by a radioactive spider for
the last 20 years I've been the one and
only spider-man and he goes through his
life and then he talks about like
getting married and then like you know
relationship falling apart Aunt May
dying you know him and Mary Jane getting
divorced him moving in by himself taking
the batteries in a shower and full
spider-man gossip crying's like I'm a
spider my gosh you're eating pizza just
being
like a depressed bachelor [ __ ] and it's
like spider-man has a rote activity for
him at this point but he because in his
personal life is in shambles and then
something strange happened and he said
which is not weird cuz strange things
happen to me all the time which I
[ __ ] love so true of that character
he's like but this was really weird and
he got taken into the jungle to her
sucked in and wound up here in this
world so you know miles is like all
right well you got teach me to be
spider-man's this guy I died and for
whatever you know reason whatever
brought you here is the same thing that
killed this guy and so we can resume but
we got to fix the goober and and there's
this moment where you know he's like you
got to teach me and he's like nah man
I'm just gonna go back into the you know
jump in the supercollider and go back to
my world and [ __ ] and miles is like the
voice who does the voice do you know
have a Peter be Parker or Miles shameik
Moore who is that he was the lead in
who's one of the leads in the get-down
wanted one of the best performances like
most natural real he's when he's talking
to him they were doing this like really
cute walk up and down walls hmm
you know Peters like goodbye I'm out of
here I got a super collider that's how I
get home goodbye and so miles is like
wait man like Peter spider-man got
killed and then Prowler trying to kill
me and you're just gonna walk what you
okay with this part of it such a really
great delivery and then Peters like yeah
I'm fine who is Jake Johnson yeah
[ __ ] fantastic dude man instant fan
of me I was like this is [ __ ] a
fantastic performance he was on the new
girl and I really like the new girl so
people say and he was in that movie
let's be cops right yeah oh he is
wonderful in this like you know it's for
honor maybe there's some purists I've
heard that are just like well you know
that ain't really Peter Parker or
whatever but it's like you know you're
missing the point of that move on it is
Peter Parker and stuff and like this I
love this version of Peter Parker
I love the gone to seed kind of like eat
it all Peter Park
yeah it's really like [ __ ] charming
like he can fight these villains in his
sleep at this point but he can't [ __ ]
tell Mary Janie sorry can't work out his
personal life or something like that so
he's becoming the teacher kind of two
miles miles was gonna have classic
spider-man be his teacher the best
spider-man and now he's got this guy
well alright I guess they decide to go
to alchemax like there's a Hudson Valley
yeah so he's like you're gonna swing
there we got to redo the goober and the
place where the goober came from is
alchemax so we got to go there and he
goes uh we're gonna swing there he goes
knowing I swing all the way that some
Valley and they show him on a bus and
then they're sitting next to each other
he's like miles you understand he's like
you want to save all your energy man you
don't want to like be swinging all the
way to Bali and then get into a fight
he's like I just had a big burger
breakfast easy swing and and then they
get off the bus there's another funny
bus like gag later on when the spider
family jumps off the bus as well like
the rationale is like what are we all
swinging for so they get out to the
Hudson Valley place break-in and and
they figure out like Peter miles rather
had seen in while he was at the Brooklyn
Academy visions Academy this movie in in
science class that talked about the
multiverse that was being narrated by
the scientific lady and stuff scientific
ladies their mouths like oh that's the
that's art that's the lady who was in
the the video that were the film that we
watched and stuff dr. Octavius yeah
which we don't find out they don't say
they've very cleverly hold our name out
into the last possible second which is
so [ __ ] good
because her reveal is great stunning
truly chilling too so I love the place
where you're going grab this bagel yeah
this bagel I'm gonna get the [ __ ] new
goober we don't go after the scientists
and they show a male scientist and then
Peter goes no other scientists is the
lady four on the bike from the video and
Peter goes oh great all right new plan
ivory examined my what is it gender
biases
collect a bag like me in place you feel
like the bagel and get out so they're
breaking in and they're trying to steal
information off a computer yeah and
that's when they find out
miles is sticking to everything miles
has real problems taking a [ __ ] you
can't let go of the roof that they came
in on miles still wearing just this like
store-bought mask and stuff and
spider-man suit and you know Peters just
like relaxed she just got relaxed and
they showed miles earlier in the movie
singing post Malone mmm
sunflower and so he's hanging from the
roof and he starts singing it and his
fingers become unstuck and then he falls
down and then like he's invisible sudden
he finds like you know Peters like oh my
god I've never seen this before and
Myles is like this normally goes not my
universe and he's it must be some sort
of fight or flight kind of thing then
the shadow of this lady doctors coming
and so boom Peter like Myles disappears
so Peter tells him like look I'll work
the lady you go hack into the computer
the lady comes into the room she's like
spider-man they cut to him he's leaning
another desk he's like oh hey I didn't
see you there and he's schlubby spider
he's wearing sweatpants the bottom half
his outfit is sweat pants he's got like
a [ __ ] four digits got and so she's
so delighted to see him and she throws
him into a chair and stuff and she's
looking at him and peeking over she's
you must be like another an altered
dimensional Peter Parker and like your
atoms must be under like attack right
now you know and she's like no I'm fine
and then he shows him glitching and [ __ ]
because that's the thing if you're not
from our universe over time your atoms
gonna break down so that's a reason to
get out of our universes by all the
spider people catch would be here 24/7
it's very like Back to the Future
it's ticking low on you here you know
that the the Polaroid people begin to
disappear and it's gonna happen to you
to mati
she didn't she tells him she's like your
you know um because he's locked in this
chair and she's facing him like and she
comes across as like very caring and
she's like be hair hippie hair and and
you know it sounds like
three teacher and she was like you know
yeah you are glitching and that's gonna
happen until every you know atom in your
body destabilizes and breaks down it is
gonna be agonizingly painful and I for
one cannot wait to watch it happen in
Peter Parker and he's like excuse me mr.
kajorn
and then he's like I'm sorry what'd you
say your name was and she's like dr.
Olivia Octavius and he's like - your
friends call you doc ock she's like no
my enemies my friends called me live and
[ __ ] the outfit appears and they do
Doc Ock but it's lady Doc Ock yep and
it's fantastic and her and she's not
like she's definitely in control and
dark and sinister but she's not like you
know this mustache twisting villains she
has a maternal tone to her she's got a
maternal tone and she is scientifically
curious and she she doesn't come across
as evil just I want to see this happen
to you and and also just yes and also
like I wanna like Fisk is using her to
breach the multiverse she just wants to
see if she's right she's scientists he
wants what he wants like suddenly you're
realizing like oh my god they're
crossing over villains this is a team-up
like it's not just kingpin and tombstone
and Prowler but Doc Ock is here like how
close are we gonna get to a [ __ ]
sinister 16 Goblin early we did so
essentially they did have six villains
right lion and scorpion shows up later
yes that's right to join the fight so
it's it's pretty [ __ ] dope man
they've got a great sequence where she
chases like an invisible spider-man like
one point he's just he can't pack in so
he's carrying a cold computer the drive
and the screen whether escaping later on
Peter Parker spider-man goes he's got
good news and bad news good news we
don't need the monitor
then there's the bagel scene which
you've seen like on the clip online when
I come into the room and there's a room
full of scientists and he's like be
casual selecting a big
hey you just your spine Cisco spider-man
real college [ __ ] and then he's like you
know I get that all the time and then
they whip out [ __ ] weapons and lasers
and they run and escape kingpin is there
as well yes my single favorite little
joke in that entire movie is when
they're escaping after the cafeteria
scene and they're running through the
double doors and what do I do with this
he goes throw the bagel throw the bagel
he throws it and there's a little side
effect of just this bagel is it the guy
in the head so good is that that's the
thing especially computer-generated like
you got a pitch that you got to pitch it
you got to say is it worth the money to
spend to render this everything about
the rendering it was a flat
two-dimensional thing that they wrote on
top yeah and like it's everything it's
that little [ __ ] joke will live in
infamy like it makes so many people
happy and the people that didn't see it
right away will see it on a second
viewing and all the the Peter porker
stuff was all hand-drawn yes you know so
like every time because I remember
seeing one of the animators was on
Twitter talking about every time Peter
porker would run spider-ham would run
they had to hand animate the like foot
like the old [ __ ] Fred Flintstone
right come by like to pull feats yeah
all of that should have to be drawn in
and like yeah nobody really remembered
how to do this because we don't do this
anymore but we it had to be this way and
they did it
it enhances the entire thing yeah he he
were are we in the story we are escaping
from alchemax
in the woods of the Hudson Valley being
chased by which you've seen online as
Peter is being taught Peters teaching
miles yes when he was like the best Jim
but everybody knows the best way to
learn is you know under total
life-threatening pressure and he's
trying to teach him to swing and while
Doc Ock is chasing them through the
woods as well and you know she's very
like Peter Parker come back here not
like I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you Peter
Parker really great performance by I
think it's Kathryn Hahn is playing yeah
Doc Ock and the boys are saved at the
last minute by another spider person
spider-woman expire Gwen Gwen herself
but in there she introduces I'm Spider
Woman the one and only Spider Woman
because naturally she wouldn't tell the
world she was spider-gwen miss Gwen
Stacy and it's a version of spider-man
that's been popular for the like the
last couple of years yeah cuz it was it
was like a one shot out of the mouths
Morales stuff mmm where'd you know Gwen
Stacy gets bitten by a radioactive
spider and she's a drummer in a rock
band and I think you know again and I
think her dad is one of them maybe not
an uncle I think it's her dad who dies
no she saves her dad she saves your dad
and Peter he's ice Peter dies right
Peter Parker her friend you know takes
some drugs and turns into the lizard and
she winds up fighting the lizard and
then he devolves into Peter and she's
like Peter and he dies in her arms so
right the reverse of gwen stacy doesn't
dying Peter's arms
Peter dies and when services are which
is characters visually stunning really
caught on there's Funko pops of the
character yeah I mean there's a bunch of
hoodies out there that that gray and
steel blue with the eyes and great idea
that caught on and then like perfect
timing for this cuz BAM she works and
we've seen her in the movie she's go
Wanda you know she was that one cuz she
C said what's your name she was gonna
say Gwen and then she was a goin Wanda
hello cuando he's like wearing from just
like South Africa so she's also trapped
and then we also get alright let's do
this one last time my name is Gwen Stacy
hmm I've bitten by a radioactive spider
and for the last like five years I've
been their one and only Spider Woman and
then she tells her origin story and then
she also got zapped to our universe in
the middle of a fight with Doc Ock and
she's been stuck here so she went to the
Brooklyn visions Academy and that's
where she ran into miles and she kind of
recognized right you're like me the
similarity and so she's been hiding out
trying to get information and so you
know she she's also looking for this but
she's glitching to she can't really
[ __ ] be out if she takes out Doc Ock
right yeah she's a hero she's a hero so
I think from that point that's when
they're like you know we should probably
like go to this place like there's only
one place like the key that really
Berber come from is fixed and you know
he's like I'm sure in this universe
there was someplace that like Peter made
this mm-hmm so like let's go back to
like you know where would he do this and
so there show up at a house and you know
Peter Parker schlubby Peter Parker's
like man I'm not ready for this and they
do a cute gag of like he just [ __ ]
flip and rings the doorbell so he's not
like near the door he's stepping a few
feet back and stuff and Lily Tomlin's
Aunt May opens the door she's great
she's fantastic
and she has a really emotional moment
where she's like Peter like cuz Peter
just died and there's this hope in her
eyes for a minute this is the first
spider-man she's run into that looks
like mmm her feet her brother is
different but Peter yeah and then he's
like he explains that like I'm from
another dimension I got blown here and
stuff and you know she's like well
you're did you guys think you were the
only ones and he's like what do you mean
the only one she's like follow me and so
she brings him out to a shed in the
backyard and Peter slubby Peter be
Parker is like oh I got one of these
where I keep my gear and you know stuff
like that
and turn the key and it's like light
show and it's essentially the entry to
the Batcave and so this version of
spider-man was like James Bond meets
Batman he's got a spider kay and she's
his out for it totally and he's got you
see the spider Jeep that we all played
with from me no choice chopper the
spider chopper like and a variety of
spider suits it's like hands down it's
this the [ __ ] Batcave and slubby
Peter Parker is just like I feel sorry
for this guy at one point like miles has
a cape on his outfit my good Peter be
Parker is like spider-man hasn't wear
cape take it off is disrespectful so
they find a spider-man that does have a
cape on and [ __ ] look Peter Parker sees
a picture of Mary Jane and it's kind of
stopped in his tracks
and stuff Aunt May
you know encourages the others to come
out of the darkness and [ __ ] and that's
where we meet the other spider family
members including spider-man noir who is
portrayed by Nick Cage which is a
fantastic Steen stealing turn and you
know like at one point stark he goes why
does you know he goes that guy in black
and white because he's always in black
and white
and he goes that guy in black and white
and he goes and why is the wind blowing
we're we're in a cave and he goes
wherever I go the wind blows and the
wind smells like rain so [ __ ] good
then they introduced penny Parker and
then they introduced spider-ham who they
made a lot more of in the trailers than
they actually do working with and you
know I'm I was borderline like he didn't
meet him but it's so [ __ ] if I'm so
glad that included them yeah it's this
perfect little grace note and John
Mulaney who does the voice does a
wonderful job Sports just leans into it
and there's and I'm always wet it's also
like the beautiful like it just gives
them a great let you know at the end
he's like yeah that's all folks and
somebody's like we legally allowed to
get a nice guy out of it so
spider-ham penny Parker spider-man noir
join up with spider-gwen or Spider Woman
spider-man Miles Morales and spider-man
slubby spider-man so there's your spider
family it's better team spider team and
so then it becomes about like well you
know in order for us to get back to our
worlds super collider
you know has to go on we all jump into
it and then somebody stays behind puts
in the goober and presses the button to
turn it off so that it doesn't destroy
the world and you know miles I'm gonna
do it this is my world everyone else is
you know going through dimensional Shock
Trauma but miles and Aunt May obviously
not this year's long universe she goes
what universe are you from he's like
Brooklyn so he's like I'm the one that
makes the most sense but then everyone's
like can you do this like and then they
start
it's not so much training montage but
it's a bunch of spider people beating up
the young to show that he's really not
[ __ ] prepared for what awaits him and
stuff I mean and it's in me it's an
Emmys house and that's when Prowler
crashes Bing bong and and [ __ ] your
parents cool tombstone King Kevin
everybody [ __ ] shows up at Aunt May's
and you know she's like take it outside
but they don't and there's a massive
spider fight against spider robe
spider-man's Monroe gallery so tombstone
is in that fight scorpion a Latino
version of scorpion doc ock relishes
prowler shows up says about four
villains and kingpin is in the mix some
well know if he comes in the house or if
he shows up later on for the private
he's like in the car later on
Choza but yes that's right it's like
what are you doing Prowler killed a kid
get out there do your job he big fight
with all the characters fight and
visually [ __ ] stunning wonderfully
fun because you know spider-ham fights
over the [ __ ] giant mallet [ __ ] like
that the the the Prowler shows up and at
one point well miles finds out that his
uncle's it probably goes to his uncle's
apartment he's writing a note going
something happened you know try to
figure out what's going on and then all
sudden the Prowler shows that because
he's dodging his father
yeah ageing his family doesn't go back
home but he goes to his uncle's house
and he leaves him as you know talking to
calls him on the phone was like hey
listen I just I need somebody to talk to
you the only one who can ever dock into
his uncle's out of town hears I'm saying
hey I'm out of town for a couple of days
so he goes to his uncle's place writes a
note and all of a sudden the Prowler
shows somebody shows up outside the
window it's [ __ ] you see his gloves
and he opens the window it's the Prowler
miles goes invisible Prowler like I'm
talking to Wilson Fisk and they takes
off his mask and then you see it's uncle
Aaron talking in his voice with a
monocle Miles knocks something over and
then there's that scene he goes out the
window at first can't see him and he
looks like he's gonna see him be on the
TV and Miles goes out the window and
there's a bit of a brand
movement and his uncle looks out the
window with a different vision like heat
vision thermal imaging and sees miles
escaping and then [ __ ] does a chase
mm-hmm miles again and somehow that ends
right yeah mouse gets away so anyway
we're back at the house and that's I
guess before that's professed before he
goes diner Peter Parker's grave miles
that's the element before us Peter
Parker's grave I think cuz that's great
because then once he gets Peter Parker
he never thought never leaves Fowler
until Prowler shows up at this big Aunt
May fight mm-hmm so Prowler you know
[ __ ] chases spider spider-man
Miles Morales spider-man like up through
the roof at a house and [ __ ] chasing
him to the end of a roof and finally
he's got him by the throat holding him
off the edge and he's clearly a kid yo
yeah but it don't matter he's just like
you know there's no roof left or nowhere
left to run or whatever and so he's
choking the [ __ ] kid and miles lifts
his mask and shows him that it's miles
and you hear him probably under the
voice of morals and he's like he's
[ __ ] choking a kid to death in this
movie and he lifts up his mask and you
see the shock in his [ __ ] face and
he's like mom's what are you doing and
he's like please uncle Aaron please and
miles feet are barely touching the
rooftop and [ __ ]
like his neck could snap at any second
and then down below is kingpin from cars
like what are you doing prowling what
are you doing you know cuz he's got the
cell phone and probably's got the head
thing like you know hurry the [ __ ] up
kill him or whatever the [ __ ]
you see prowler [ __ ] lower spider-man
the miles mask over his face again and
in that moment you're like I I don't
know what's gonna happen like that's a
crimson [ __ ] today like you know what
as long as you're spider-man I could do
my job don't see your face it really
dark but then he steps back and puts the
kid on his own feet and [ __ ] and
he takes one breath and then BAM he shot
in the [ __ ] food back and they reveal
kingpin get the gun out having shot
Prowler from down below and then he aims
at at Peter but miles [ __ ] that's
tough and miles runs away and stuff so
suddenly he picks up prowlers body and
swings off the cops are [ __ ] showing
up and [ __ ] and so he takes prowler to
his side alley where is his final
moments with his uncle dying you know
and he he doesn't do the with great
power comes great responsibility they
make a joke about that at one point like
Myles is like with great power and you
know Peter schlubby Peter Parker's like
don't you dare finish saying that I'm so
tired of that I'm over it so he has
moment miles to talk to his uncle on his
uncle's just like you the best of us
miles yeah just keep going you there man
just keep going and then he dies and
some miles is heartbroken and feels
responsible and then the cop car pulls
up and it's his dad his dad comes over
the fence and he just sees a kid like
laying over a body and you know
spider-man outfit freeze you know
suddenly I go leashes classic comic book
storytelling is why he hates spider-man
smiles goes invisible gets away but then
Jeff sees that his brother Aaron is dead
and calls it in he's like I want an APB
on spider-man so suddenly the seeds of
like write a hatred for spider-man which
I will point out they did an entire
movie no Jay no Jay jonah jameson a
single [ __ ] reference no Daily Bugle
like just it's amazing you don't need it
you don't need totally get away with it
and I think they were also really smart
because he in a moment it's the put on
an APB on spider-man you think it's
going to be this long running like
simmering fuel I see what act 2 is like
totally it's adverse son dad vs. son to
give you such a good a move in that
thing keep the secret and it's gonna go
on forever and you know dad hates
spider-man but loves me and I love my
dad but I am spider-man and they defuse
it like 15 minutes later yeah because
you don't actually want that story you
got they got so much other story to tell
they're like look at all these
spider-man yeah and a girl yes by the
woman we've got are nothing but conflict
we got some [ __ ] to do here we can we
and this we can resolve this in such a
way that an audience he can go home
saying you know what what I wanted was
this family to get back together and I
want them to all believe that they're
back together and know the truth about
one another because the only way for
miles to be the person you're supposed
to be by embracing everything that is is
by letting his own his dad in on it yeah
you know look I heard you dad I'm
embracing the Sparkletts with him miles
you know in the spider cave after
getting his ass beat a few times and
knocked over and whatnot is realizing
you know they go off to have a huddle to
talk about him and essentially they're
you know they're all saying like this
guy's not ready
we're Fox he can't do it like this kids
too green and blah blah blah miles takes
off leaves a spider cave forgives her
his dorms goes to his dorm and then is
looking at his book where he did is no
expectations tag and throws out the
window then it comes back Peter shows up
give him the pep talk a little bit but
then they're all show up and they've
shown up to say goodbye they're gonna do
this without him and he's like no I
could do this and they're like you can't
and Peter sweeps his legs out and grabs
him by the [ __ ] shirt and shows them
how fast he is and then webs into the
chicken to the chair which is a really
great gag very visual gag and they they
have a million beautiful sight gags that
that just they're not wasted they're all
fantastic but I can't remember them all
that continue to elevate this movie
every step yeah and he webs into the
chair and he says I'm ready I can help
you honestly if you're ready then then
venom blast your way out of the chair
return visible like yeah do any of the
things that you you're able to do and he
can't do it so then you're not ready and
they all just leave and he's by himself
I also went off into the sunset yeah to
go save the world as the spider family
yeah which you've instantly just bought
into oh yeah like the same way that
everyone go okay I'll do this one last
time they could did one for spider-man
noir he had his origin he's a 1930s
like guy in a mask you know with guns
who punches and loves egg creams and
like
like he says [ __ ] like you know we don't
pick the ballroom we just do the dance
you know he's that guy and so then they
show penny Parker's origin her father
was killed radioactive spider controls
this gigantic robot that her father
built that she gets inside of and fights
from inside of him that's the my
spider-man in 2349 or whatever the [ __ ]
and Peter porker of course the
spectacular spider-man is bitten by
radioactive pig they show at one point
everyone's a spider and he goes big and
and so they get their own like many
origins and stuff and they were all
blasted here in the same [ __ ] way
dimensional rift so they all got to get
home so they all operate they all know
to be spider-man and suddenly he
realized oh there's a story about how
miles has to learn how to be spider-man
or else [ __ ] that said this is you
gotta take a leap of faith and that's
what Peter Parker tells them before he
goes how would I know what I'm ready to
be spider-man and he goes you don't
you'll never know miles it's just a leap
of faith that's all it is pulls on his
mask and go swings away and [ __ ] so
miles concentrates and [ __ ] venom
punches his way out of the [ __ ] well
first that's this dad shows up oh and
they have a conversation a conversation
through the door really beautiful scene
yeah where the dad knows the son is on
the other side of the door and sees the
shadow right it's like I know you're not
ready to talk to me at mouth because he
won't answer because his mouth is
whipped correct I've been calling you
understand you don't want to talk yet
and I know you hear but just I gotta say
some stuff you know I don't want to push
you I don't want to prod you I know like
if you don't want to go to the school
that's fine like we just we love you to
death but we realize that there's a
spark in you you're special and we just
want to find ways to nurture the special
that's within you so when you're ready
to talk we'll be here and he just leaves
and does the I love you just in the
beginning like he's like a lot of miles
and then has the nice bit of calling
over the loudspeaker like you gotta say
I love you say letters in front of
everybody and [ __ ] so it's a callback he
says he loves him but miles ain't
responding and his dad takes that to
mean like all right I get it yeah I've
said what I came to say and stuff and
you know you'll talk when you're ready
yeah and leaves what miles can't say
anything now you just hear like his head
just sort of silently like not against
the door cuz he also cants you know
[ __ ] bang his head against door and
tells dad to open the door if his dad
sees him all webbed up right spider-man
his worst so that's when he powers up
gets out of the [ __ ] webbing and [ __ ]
like that and that's where they start
the [ __ ] what's up danger that he
goes to milk me a stranger's Aunt May's
and she's like about time yes and weeds
like I made these for you they fit
perfectly and he grabs the spider suit
and tags it paints it makes it his own
and she yeah then heads off to try to
swing and go to the top of buildings a
fantastic montage that you can see on
lion it's it is it is one of my favorite
like becoming a hero
moments in any movie ever made and him
blasting off the side of the building
the ass breaking under his fingertips
yes interested being upside down so he's
actually soaring higher even though he's
actually falling and yeah I just don't
get a little misty little verklempt even
though it's it's beautiful and it's so
funny like how there's this accepted
language of Spider Man by that point in
the movie that even if you were came
into that not ever knowing anything
about spider-man
they have spoon-fed you okay let's do
this again I was bit by Ray you have
enough origins and you have enough like
this is what that character does we've
seen them all [ __ ] swing and this kid
is learning and this is the night the
moment where he [ __ ] breaks free and
and it's beautiful and as he's [ __ ]
plummeting to the [ __ ] ground you
know they're still montaging and showing
Aunt May giving him the web-shooters and
saying they fit perfectly I made it
myself and then funny fine just before
he's about to hit he [ __ ] blast them
they go to the top of the tower can stop
me now and he's just swinging through
the [ __ ] New York oh it's fantastic
it's it's awesome and it's it's that
moment where like just after the hero
has his darkest moment which is he's
left he's abandoned he can't connect
with his dad all of his friends have
left him alone strapped to a chair
it's the here as a person who's
fundamentally not the same guy you
when the movie started like he's changed
she's not it's not just because he got
bit by a spider like that's not what
makes you spider-man
it's the embracing the fact that you
have a responsibility and that you have
people who love and the city that you
love and it's it's it's being ready to
accept that with great power comes great
responsibility and then he's a [ __ ]
hero he leaps off that building a boy he
swings to the ground as a man he swings
across and he finally lifts up the mask
yeah looks back all right
and that's when BAM he gets his own
comic book yeah Miles Morales number one
that hadn't been does his name on the
car too and who was it bender Sara
Pacelli I think that kiss so miles was
he Alton he was an Ultimate Universe it
was like spectacular spider-man number
one or something like that but it was it
was just spider-man number one was it
set in our universe or the universe of I
don't it's not the ultimate universe not
really it's just one of the many of the
like the Bendis multiverse that he
invented so he wasn't contemporary of
Peter Parker I know they did a story
where they teamed up and crossed over
chip yeah they did one on the cartoon
and I think Donald Glover voiced Miles
Morales yeah in the cartoon that's but
yeah there it required a dimensional
shift for Miles Morales to actually meet
Peter Parker so he we see our spider
team has gone to Brooklyn where Fisk is
having a ball and it's in honor of
[ __ ] spider-man and Mary Jane is
there to speak and all the waitstaff are
in [ __ ] spider-man masks and [ __ ] and
you know you get a few good jokes like
with spider-gwen looking at Fisk on what
a pig and it's better ham being like I'm
right here and and spider you're
spider-man know everything like look at
their masks and you see they're all
spider-man he's like it can't be that
easy and then suddenly they're just on
the floor
blending in because they also have
spider-man math so they look like the
waitstaff and petabyte a man or Peter
Parker sees Mary Jane and has this
moment where he breaks off
you know he's just yet another guy Tiger
man I asked I gotta go tell her how I
feel right and she's like hi I was
wondering if we could get more bread at
our table and he's like yeah he's gone
I'm just I'm sorry she's like you know
have to apologize he goes I wasn't there
for you like I just and she's like I
just want a bread like I promise the
next time I see you I know I will be the
person you need to bring you more bread
so they know that the supercollider is
being charged up under this [ __ ] big
shindig and they all need it to get home
mm-hmm but somebody else I think
schlubby Peter Parker is gonna stay
behind right because that universe is
Peter Parker is dead anyway so he'll do
it he'll get him through right and man
amazed alive here and there's still a
Mary Jane but he has a really really
like he gets really nice performance
beats in that character not just funny
he's legit funny throughout and he has
an authentic New York sounding voice
yeah but also like pretty like the Mary
Jane beat the the beat with Aunt May
like tender rocking moments - he's a
good you know feckless teacher mm-hmm
they they use Peter Parker so
interestingly and so well and use the
trope of like world-weary
I've done this a thousand times like and
not self-aware like I'm in a comic book
but just right I've done this so often
kid like at one point like kingpin is
talking to the lady doctor before we
know it's Doc Ock and he's miles is up
in the roof with Peter in the
air-conditioning duct and Peter's like
this pretty standard spider-man stuff
you watch he's gonna say you have 24
hours when they cut down stairs and
kingpin goes
you have 24 hours to make this work and
I got back up to spider-man and and mild
spider-man and Peter Parker spider-man
does the wink with the one of the others
like I've done this a thousand times kid
oh [ __ ] like that that just makes it
magic so miles shows up to the
supercollider
they all know kingpin knew they were
coming and so they're prepared for him
and big fight ensues right and then in
that fight is the first time we see what
he wants to get out of the collider
because he turns the collider on and we
did a little montage prior to that when
he was on the is clicking his pen that's
where they did the flashback and showed
you how Wilson Fisk lost his family
right so this the super collider starts
a probe goes up and inside you start
seeing various versions of his wife and
his his kid like you know like they take
their hurt hair from a comb or something
like that to do a DNA search and the
multiverse and stuff but in doing that
that's gonna rip open a hole in reality
kill everybody blah blah blah but he
don't care he's a man who wants what he
lost and he lost it because of his
actions
but he's got all the money in the world
and no conscience conscience conscience
just a villain with a broken heart
he's killed bill yeah it's just you know
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] who also bleeds
when cut in the heart and wants to try
to rectify something that you can't once
broken can't be fixed so as poignant as
Shakespearean really is really
bittersweet so the world is dimensions
are crashing into one another reality as
being upended inside the supercollider
buildings are forming within buildings
trains are moving ish it and you see a
little bit of the outer world like you
see sort of Manhattan itself do you know
throb like an equalizer almost as people
being like what's going on and the cop
dad you know heading off toward the
danger here a hero himself mm-hmm like
his son so within the super collider you
know they they fight Doc Ock and she's
there and [ __ ] like that and they get
the moment to turn it all on and and you
know everyone has their
I thing so you know spider-gwen you know
drops out into the who's the first one I
think spider-man noir is the first one
to go yeah at one point he has a Rubik's
Cube and [ __ ] he's like I'm gonna take
this much so this book because he can't
tell the colors apart what is purple now
he's like I'm gonna take this thing with
me I don't know what it is but I will
figure it out and then drops into his
world under pork ago Peter porker goes
with a tear and gives him a [ __ ]
hammer put in his back because it'll fit
in your back pocket and then that's when
he says that's all folks and he dives
back in his universe and somebody's like
oh even legally allowed say yeah this
Mandy Parker goes penny Parker goes well
they have a big fight inside the super
collider at one point the scorpion gets
the better of Penny Parker and it's this
version of scorpion you've never really
seen before
you're like seven or eight legs or
something yeah like really looks like a
cybernetic scorpion ship and his tail
[ __ ] punctures you know her suit like
and she gets he gets saved she gets
saved to the last second by an anvil
drops on his head and that's from Peter
Parker and then the Scorpion sees him
he's like you a little cartoon and he's
like you got a problem with cartoons and
then he [ __ ] whips out the hammer and
[ __ ] beats the [ __ ] at a at a
scorpion but penny Parker's suit that a
rad bill but the giant robot that has
expressions on his face is dying and
they actually [ __ ] get you to feel
sad for this robot like cuz his last his
eyes flash as two hearts at her and then
kind of go out and she's heartbroken
she's represented as an anime character
but she opens a little trapdoor and out
comes the spider who said it's okay
we'll make another one that didn't
happen
but but that's the impression I get real
purist I'm like that didn't happen
yeah that's what I want to about dare
you but they even have they kill the
suit and get some poignancy out of it
it's pretty impressive so she goes she
dives back in with her spider and [ __ ]
spider-gwen
dives in that leaves just Peter and
and my smiles but kingpin has shown up
mm-hm and you know I was like forces
Peter to go into the [ __ ] thing Peter
don't want to go Peters like you can't
take this guy by yourself
and you know he's like Pete sweeps
Peters leg the same way Peter swept his
catches him by the shirt and he's
holding him over the [ __ ] abyss
that's gonna send him back to his
universe and Peter Parker's schlubby
Peter Parker scared about going back
he'd rather stay here and fight the
kingpin than if I could go back to his
world because he's like what if I get it
wrong again I think goes you won't you
go to your right to leap of faith and he
lets me go and shall I be Peter Parker
goes back to his universe and miles the
hero the hero Rises cheese stands alone
to take on [ __ ] kingpin one-on-one
and miles is to be fair like you know
only maybe double the height of
spider-ham you still represented as deal
boy yes and kingpin looks like a [ __ ]
monster and is enraged because what he
wanted is now they've turned off the
super collider it's out of fun and reach
and he's saying to crank it up all the
way so he's gonna [ __ ] he's like I
can't wait to kill you know -
spider-man's and like he starts fighting
them and kingpin is like almost [ __ ]
unbeatable and [ __ ] and meanwhile his
dad shows up as reality of shifting in
the super collider his cop dad it was
like seeing spider-man tiny-ass
spider-man fighting this [ __ ] giant
monster and [ __ ] like that suddenly
seeing him through a different prism
like oh my god cuz he's biased like all
throughout like one point miles runs
away after he gets bit and [ __ ] when he
runs home and his parents find him in
his room when he's supposed to be at the
academy and you know it's after there
was an earthquake because after the
super collider went off and [ __ ] like
that
so his mom's like let him stay here Jeff
and and he asked his dad he's like dad
do you really hate spider-man his dad
like yeah
another really great performance moment
[ __ ]
and she's like honey yeah just get out
of here and he's like baby you know I
feel bad like real shitty so here he is
seeing spider-man be a hero like holding
there holding the very walls of reality
together while fighting this gigantic
[ __ ] monster he don't know it's miles
was just looking at the suit and he's
like clearly it's me and this guy are
the only two [ __ ] people here and and
standing between the brink of beingness
being in nothingness earlier he was the
guy that was like spider-man he comes in
once a day zips up that been his little
mask and you know it answers to nobody
so his guy he's a cop and he's got a
complicated relationship with this
vigilante but in this moment he sees
this vigilante as the Euro that he is
meanwhile miles get the crap kicked out
of my the [ __ ] everliving kingpin and
[ __ ]
and it puts him down and he's like you
know you think you can beat me you're
not even the real spider-man and he
[ __ ] takes him down and [ __ ] beats
him into the ground and [ __ ] and King
again kingpin is represented not just
like oh he's bigger than miles he's no
he's a mountain he's a mountain and so
spider-man is face down on the ground
and of course the recurring theme is
like you got to get out for spider-man
always gets up so his dad who don't know
it's his kid see spider-man down on the
ground and the swirling unreality with
kink and hovering over him and [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] huge his dad's just like get up
spider-man and then you got the moment
where miles passing it up this big par
spider-man continuity they did that in
homecoming as well where he was like get
up spider-man that comes right from that
very famous issue where spider-man is
does that literally [ __ ] talks
himself into like if I don't do this
people die get up spider-man so [ __ ]
moving so beautiful and miles [ __ ]
gets up and then does the thing that his
uncle taught him the shoulder [ __ ]
tag he's just like puts his hand on
kingpins shoulder and he goes hey
kingpins like what but that's his bet
punch kicks in and blast [ __ ] blast
kingpin off the building and [ __ ] is
that they're fighting on in this warping
reality and then he webs him and [ __ ]
uses kingpin swings and he's like
kingpin press the button for me and
hurls him up to the top of the collider
so kingpin presses the button
inadvertently that shuts everything
[ __ ] down and blows up and [ __ ] like
that and saves the [ __ ] day and you
know everything starts going back to
normal and [ __ ] and so you see tombstone
get arrested like a woman please put in
the back of a cop car doc ock gets
arrested doc ock gets killed does she
get killed while they're fighting like
she gets hit by a train like she's like
first it's like Peter like she shows up
first before kingpin mm-hmm and just as
like Peters about to you know jump in or
whatever and he's like you can't do this
alone and so they both fight he's like
this is gonna take a while and then also
she gets hit by a train and they're like
well oh these nine kingpin shows up so
so his dad you know is there on the
scene putting tombstone in the car and
[ __ ] and then he gets a call from Miles
his son and he answers a music Myles and
so Myles is talking to him from the
rooftop looking down on a [ __ ] and his
dad it's like well you're safe that's
the important thing and like you know
Myles you know your uncle you know he
was trying to tell him through the door
something about his uncle he was like
you know I know you like the tag and
he's like so there's some space you know
in the precinct that maybe you can come
down and put up your artwork like he's
trying to bend because his dad earlier
in the movie was like you can go around
town you pick all those stickers off but
he's like you saw all those he goes I
saw him also miles puts up tags his dad
who's a cop is like take things down so
his dad saying like you know there's
place we could go
reaching out tag reaching out and also
you saw how much it meant to miles of
his Uncle Sam I'll shows up like he's
like miles miles and on the phone he
says something about us coverage but all
sudden spider-mans there and he's like
officer and McGee go spider-man like if
that happens so [ __ ] often like Doc
Ock does too at one point she's like
when Miles shows up she's like
spider-man
like it's such a comic book yeah like in
the scientist later on I liked him
earlier with the bagel bit where it
spider-man like there's that that to me
was such comic-book DNA there's always
this moment of spider-man how could you
what everyone's always surprised and
it's like how can you be surprised at
this point so yes there's a you know
he's expired man and he goes he's true
miles are trying to do an adult voices I
gotta look forward to working with you
try to be lucky boys he's like I look
forward to work with Jews like no I
don't approve of your vigilante methods
and then he's like he gives him a hug
and he's a go well alright of course and
then he's like I love you who what he's
like well thank you very is like you
still don't know they love these thank
you you gotta say it back is so [ __ ]
sweet
so you know at that point then he goes
my name is Miles Morales you know for
the last two days I've been in the one
and only spider-man and blah blah blah
and so we end on the note of like he's
come he's become the hero he lived up to
what Peter dying Peter Parker made him
problem taxed with him promised him and
he grew into it and here is the euro and
there's others out there like him and he
says anyone could wear the mask you
could wear the mask you know as he
swings through New York and [ __ ] and
then the movie ends it's [ __ ]
wonderful and then they do a
post-credits sequence where they show
spider-man 2099 that Peter David created
I really I think so if I remember he was
like the architecture that 2099 stuff
yeah of that universe yet so you know
and it's Oscar Isaacs voicing him and
like right Miguel he lives in Nuevo York
and so there he's entering the [ __ ]
spider-verse the stream and [ __ ] and he
gets zapped back to the cartoon the
classic spider-man environment and that
meme of spider-man pointing at spider
man from that one episode of the guy who
dressed up like Spider me so he shows up
a spider-man 2099 but in that animation
style pointing at [ __ ] like you're
you're spider-man you're you're stop
pointing your pointing you're pointing
first like they even honored that
[ __ ] meme online yeah every single
piece of spider-man universe was Tesla
it was really [ __ ] beautiful but they
can make a thousand of these it did
everything it was trying to do so well
look I loved it but I've always loved
spider-man and you know once again there
are many iterations there but I got to
imagine like for somebody who's not a
white guy to sit there and see that
story yeah I saw so many people on
Twitter like I took my little cousin
like all he runs around now is swinging
he never seen his face up on the screen
like yeah I mean it's it's there were a
couple of times that I teared up at this
movie and not the least of which was
really early on when it's just oh my god
this thing exists like it just it's it's
in this world has been conjured from
like pure imagination into something
that yeah like an eight-year-old kid can
go to the movies and see himself and
that'd 47 year old kid can go to the
movies and see himself it's a it is it's
astonishing and the fact that it's good
you know yes it's one thing to have
representation and that bad means a lot
you know if if we learn nothing from
this year from Black Panther and the
reception to the Captain Marvel trailer
on the heels of Wonder Woman's that
would you know representation counts for
a lot
well and people will show out for that
but you know it it never hurts for like
a kid to see themselves be a hero you
know like it's funny there was there was
a little bit of chatter that I DW was
relaunching The Rocketeer
mm and yeah and I think they were sort
of updating it it was less like you know
cliff Secord bunch of Nazis in the face
because gonna be something like a
modern-day take like a kid finds the
tank yeah and I rocked it back and I
think that the sales the pre-orders were
not high enough and so I did have you
cancelled a book oh and you know I just
kept thinking to myself like if you
can't sell a book about a kid who finds
a jetpack
to fly then like that's a problem yeah
because there's always gonna be an
audience for that like this always can
beat audience for a kid of any color of
any stripe but boy or girl whatever who
learns to do the impossible my shame you
know well they showed it to us and maybe
maybe this movie helps that same [ __ ]
way maybe it's like look like give it
some time like don't cancelled again try
it like let it build maybe the book like
hits later on maybe issue three it
[ __ ] connects but like somebody out
there wants to see themselves wearing
the rocket pack
totally totally like and I never thought
that you know again not just in a year
where this is the best black superhero
movie but it's the best animated
superhero movie in a year that had
Incredibles - agreed you know like this
it's it's it is a work of art and for me
I saw it two days in a row back-to-back
you did you loved it that's why I could
do this story so [ __ ] well I didn't
see it once I saw it [ __ ] twice and
I'm sure I'm and I got an Oscar screener
soon yes they should push hard towards
it because they're gonna win yeah it it
may be my favorite movie of the year
now some people be like nitrogen of
moving man figured cartoon whatever
split airs all you want like I like uh
it stands at least shoulders shoulders
with Avengers infinity war which I've
watched [ __ ] now 52 times so [ __ ]
I'm I'm way deep on this I obviously
love that movie but like this movie
within two viewings went right next to
that movie that's how [ __ ] strong it
is this is classic storytelling and it
had the DNA of all my favorite things in
the world and it had cooks that worked
on [ __ ] that I liked before like it it's
got the DNA that Lord and Miller team
who could walk away with an Oscar in a
year where they got bounced from [ __ ]
solo yeah like it's a beautiful
cinematic experience quite like the lego
movie when I walked out going like [ __ ]
I'm makes me feel I got to be a better
human being because it gives you
everything you wanted you think you want
from that world like the lego movie was
just it was candy colored and fun
pure popcorn entertainment you know pop
culture just miasma in your face yeah
and then it reveals his beating heart
that you didn't even know was there you
know this movie does the same thing it's
like I'm giving you spider-man like I'm
giving you the best spider-man you've
ever seen on screen before and then oh
by the way I agree with that hands-down
like at its core it is this like
wonderful story about family and and the
lengths to which you will go to build a
family and to hold on to the family you
have it's it's work of art is the least
we could say about it man like this is
what every storyteller should strive for
I remember when I first saw like the
Pixar movies I was like this [ __ ]
this is amazing
why don't they do superhero movies like
this and then they did the Incredibles
and I'm again I was amazing but why
don't they do the superheroes ID and now
they will like it made a bunch of money
to open number one and [ __ ] like that
which means when they do it again now
they've built an audience in for it like
they'll come out and [ __ ] and these you
know you can get anybody do voices and
these characters never age
like you know it's they could keep doing
this with everybody imagine they gave
you a Batman movie this like you know
world where people like man another
Batman they found an interesting way to
[ __ ] give you spider-man
you served up fresh give us and give us
like a [ __ ] your warner brothers home
of animation [ __ ] Bugs Bunny in all
this [ __ ]
like give us an animated movie as
[ __ ] fine as that you feature in the
Dark Knight you're doing [ __ ] where you
couldn't do it normally and you'd get
anybody to voice that [ __ ] thing yeah
like some rock rock star [ __ ] actor
or actress whatever the [ __ ] you're
gonna do because it's just a voice in a
[ __ ] you know CG movie but oh god I
can't wait to own this this will be my
new go-to I got nothing to do I'm scuzzy
or and smoking watch certain key
sequences of course but like I connected
with this movie in a big bad way I you
know I went back second day dragged my
wife to and [ __ ] she was there for most
of it and she fell asleep I was like man
why am I married get me and
she was just like opposites attract and
like yeah I guess they say that somebody
said that justify why they don't like
the shipper husband exit but afterwards
she goes well you watch did it hold up
second viewing I said it really did like
to me that is a magical [ __ ] movie
yeah I only saw that once I'm trying to
figure out what I'm gonna see it again
and I want to seen it IMAX 3d outs are
so I didn't see 3d but I saw tonight
yeah and the first time Jesus it was
[ __ ] huge
yeah I mean and the other thing of it is
is that it's in the Marvel multiverse
like there is a world in which Miles
Morales with more dimensional chicane er
II can absolutely cross over into the
mainstream I mean look I give it max
five years before they [ __ ] do it
yeah in the in the live-action world
like it's just the tables now set
they've proven it's a viable character
yeah or to go the other way and bring
the Avengers into this Miles Morales
universe right you know and to tell it
like a full-on [ __ ] comic book
crossover and get all the voices like
hey we we got [ __ ] Hemsworth to do
Thor we got this to happen we got our DJ
back all of this stuff like you could
absolutely true in five years and bridge
into that world yeah I mean and what all
right so last time like Feige and
and Robert Downey jr. deeply involved in
a Sony movie spider-man homecoming foggy
over see this new one far from home cuz
it's got yeah hoagie in it mmm-hmm happy
Hogan and it's got yeah I think it'll
still be produced by Kevin Feige I think
so he's got his fingers in this [ __ ]
pie I think everything that Tom Holland
is involved in is part of the MCU
technically I mean it's technically Sony
but Disney gives a [ __ ] right because
they're sharing them and mm-hmm
and it works for everybody I love that
we live in this period where we can have
a conversation like this out a
meaningful conversation the world is
going to [ __ ] around us but oh the
Marvel Universe is the best place in the
world to live on islands in the stream
who knew kids you don't understand we
were we had Dolph Lundgren
as the Punisher and we would sit there
and go like why can't Marvel ever get
one just like any one of these would be
great they've got such great [ __ ] IP
why can't they ever get a movie right
and [ __ ] now they can't get him wrong
now the ones that aren't even you know
Kevin Feige Marvel yeah you got Deadpool
twice up you got Logan [ __ ] crushed
it and now this like you know it's I
know they make the joke and once upon a
Deadpool or whatever about like well
you're not real Marvel yeah you're Fox
Marvel yeah I don't know man like Fox
Marvel killing it Sony Marvel killing it
right now Marvel just killing it across
the boards man there ain't no [ __ ]
nobody talks about the Inhumans anymore
no but [ __ ] like those though and
even like you know an iron fist which
took a lot of hits with people being
like [ __ ] this show like people miss
these Netflix shows going away they they
were a big part of their [ __ ] lives I
mean had grown into deep relationships
with these characters I actively
disliked possibly even loathed venom
right but vote yeah yeah oh you did I
didn't tell you what I thought I and I
watched it like I watched it at home so
I had a good time I was sitting there
going I can't believe this works like
this doesn't look like any other comic
book movie I've ever seen in my life
bears very little resemblance with that
just seems like Minoo comparison for it
yeah nothing i'd i just it felt like 87
different movies all happening once and
Tom Hardy is doing whatever the [ __ ] he
wants to do which apparently people want
to see because he is actually a magnetic
actor but from one scene to the next I
don't understand what that character
wants or is doing it's been made 860
million dollars worldwide without real
and venom doesn't come into it until
like 55 minute mark now and then when
he's there there's a couple sequences
but like I get it like he's a
cool-looking character the whole time I
was watching there's one moment I
literally laughed out loud at something
where I was like what the [ __ ] oh where
he was just like talking about at one
point he's like you know
don't follow their heads and leave a
pile of their dead bodies in them in the
corner of the room and he was like why
yeah like that movies made more than
Wonder Woman is made there's an audience
and that you know what it means - you
can't deny now like it felt like they're
like we're not [ __ ] letting
spider-man touch this like spider-man is
[ __ ] gold man whose venom they better
go prove himself after making eight
hundred million bucks you better you
know who's showing up in the next movie
if only for a little bit and [ __ ]
spider-man yeah oh you're gonna you got
it you have to like and now it's no
reason not to I don't take a little that
800 million oh I don't know what fart
what for homecoming made spider-man
homecoming I don't know I mean that they
that seems to be I'm not gonna say par
for the course but between 700 and 900
feels like if you're making a real
superhero movie that audience connect
with that's about what you're making all
right it's really good if you really get
your you cross the billion dollar mark
if you're special you cross like the two
billion dollar mark everything Marvel
right now it's making me happy man
Marvel is killing it across the boards
like just great storytelling original
storytelling this [ __ ] spider-verse
movie you don't you know what I don't
even know you don't take this the wrong
way you don't deserve this but it's a
[ __ ] beautiful and good this is man
this is like this movie is like finding
you ever hear that Willie Nelson song
angel flying too close to the ground one
of the saddest [ __ ] songs this is
Lynn I mean there was more about like
finding somebody and nurse them back to
health and they [ __ ] off anyway not a
true angel no this is literally like
finding an angel with a broken wing
getting to nurse that angel back to
health and and and like until that wing
gets better and then that angels gonna
[ __ ] leave you this metaphor phone
thing I don't know it's just this is
like finding Aladdin's lamp this is such
a rare treasure this film the DNA of
which we all share and it was made by
people
just like us clearly more talented but
just like us who love the same [ __ ] we
love and when I say us it's not like a
white guy like Colin what is that dog
whistling enjoy that that would exclude
mark and that'd be weird I mean us I'm
excluding others this is true those of
us who have lived their lives by these
stupid-ass codes of characters that are
fake their characters aren't real people
but I never met finer human beings in my
life than I met in the pages of comic
books these people made me want to be a
better person this movie makes you want
to be a better person it reminds me of
the thrill of opening a [ __ ] comic
book and falling in love with a world
escapism but learning something and not
just cheap escapism for the sake of like
[ __ ] like I've burned two hours
walking away with a moral like this is
the tsa's are [ __ ] the morality store
tails the same way that like Greeks and
Romans were raised with stories of gods
and vengeance to teach them right from
wrong and then [ __ ] Christians you
know and invaded the world with stories
about do this cuz heaven and if you
don't there's a hell you know our
generation this is what we got and we
read them in the books and now we get to
see him writ large on the giant screen
and watching it come to life was
thrilling being in on the joke is fun
and [ __ ] but being able to appreciate
the fact that that movie works for
anybody you don't have to know [ __ ]
[ __ ] about spider-man this could be the
first thing you've first time you ever
heard the concept in your life of a
spite or anything the movie brings you
in into its bosom welcomes you gently
doesn't alienate you and lets you learn
about this fascinating [ __ ] character
through many dimensions I'll tell you
what if this was your first introduction
to spider-man oh my god it would [ __ ]
you for everything
you'd never watch that Tobey Maguire
thing it was this oh my god it's just so
[ __ ] wonderful and beautiful yeah
it's it's patient zero for all things
that are great like this was your first
thing if this was your induction to
you're the luckiest person in the world
that's a giant bar to like from now on a
lot of [ __ ] will be judged against this
where you're just like I mean [ __ ] I
feel
good luck to the next spider-man movie
yet good luck far from home yeah you got
it and look I'm sure they'll do it they
got Mysterio that's their secret weapon
but like this was a high [ __ ] bar
that was set and I believe in that kid I
like him a spider-man tom hollie and
I'll you know so far those movies have
been [ __ ] pitch perfect I haven't he's
great it's Peter Parker
oh and and they know what they're doing
and [ __ ] so I bet you they'll be an
emotional cook of some sort but yeah
this this had every this was like
playing poker with 12 aces up your
sleeve like the deck was so loaded in
their favor and it was an expert dealer
who could deal from top bottom middle
whatever it was like being dealt a hand
of [ __ ] cards by Ricky Jay all these
cats these directors I was shouted the
movie out on Instagram give it a review
and stuff and one of the filmmakers was
like thanks and like I said oh my god
you're doing the Lord's work or some
such [ __ ] it's funny I started a matinee
at a theater up on my house and near
Chatsworth California hmm it was it was
the first showing of the day and I took
my son and there was a row of dudes
sitting in front of me all grown-ups all
whatever it would clearly come out
together and you know we all sat through
the credits and like when somebody's
name came up
like the row of dudes was like yeah so
we get out to the lobby and they're all
like taking pictures in front of the big
like lobby billboard I was like ah which
one of you worked on the movie like we
were all in VFX rendering we were all
doing this it was like well [ __ ] done
gentlemen like that was outstanding I
would agree with that I would totally
stop and blow him for a minute yeah
especially coming out of holy [ __ ] oh
it's a [ __ ] triumph what a fantastic
man this is even if you're like well I
was gonna see you maybe you don't like
comic books why would you be listening
to and Beyond but you don't like
spider-man even if you're like I'm a DC
purist [ __ ] Marvel this is the one to
break that yeah on it's so much charm oh
all much love all the lots of passion
play in the best way I can't wait for I
mean this is the shittiest thing to say
to a bunch of people that took I don't
know how many years to make that make
these before
maybe six I want the next one as soon as
possible yeah why don't I have it ready
best and worst thing to say to somebody
who I loved it when you're doing another
one I just showed you a miraculous
[ __ ] magic trick and you want another
one I'm like yeah pull off his victory
lap before I even finish the circuit I'm
American I'm greedy man I'm a glutton
please more more MORE excellent and if
they don't give it to me I will turn on
you
this is this is I think you agree with
you my favorite movie of the year and I
think this might be for me the best
superhero movie I've seen in a decade
I'm with you on that and that doesn't
lower anything else does low anything
out doesn't mean Avengers infinity war
is any less amazing than it [ __ ] is
but like holy [ __ ]
like these these two movie stand
shoulder shoulder and look one of the
things they both have in common is they
get the job done with way more than one
character and that's also the impressive
thing to hell them both for is that like
they're balancing so many [ __ ]
storylines yeah and yet it works yeah
and not only I mean the Avengers
infinity war isn't introducing that many
of them they've just got a service 50
[ __ ] characters right this has to
introduce those introduces almost
everybody is brand new except for you
know a couple of Peter Parker's and Aunt
May everybody else is a brand new
character to the audience and so to
introduce them all give them all stories
give them more reasons for being there
let us know who they are on how they
differentiate it's easy when one of them
is a pig but still like it's it's a lot
of work to balance all of that just
right to keep all those balls in the air
and not drop a single one I love that
they did [ __ ] that I never would have
dreamed of but I was like that was
perfect it made me a better writer I
walked out of that movie and I got to
write a story for a detective 1000 that
Jim Lee's gonna draw and it was first it
was like man I gotta write about Batman
like right now all I want to do is write
about smarter but it made me go like oh
when I do do it this is I've gotta up my
game to this maybe ratchet up and go a
little harder than I think I would have
been stuff but little [ __ ] that I never
thought of but this must be so true in
all of their universes there must be an
Aunt May yeah like and the thing that
binds them all together is that they've
all lost somebody
during them you know I was like you're
nothing like me no we're all like you
Peter yeah well I think it was my uncle
give me it was my Uncle Ben and
Spiderman was like for me it was my
uncle Benjamin penny Parker is like for
me it was my father
Gwen Stacy for it says from for me it
was my friend
that's Peter Berg yeah loss is the thing
that binds them all together Peter
porker just sweeps and says like the
hardest thing about this job is you
can't save them all so he doesn't have a
for me it was right you know
another Pig for me it's bacon it's weird
they show me hot dogs all the time it's
like don't you get it you're a pig it is
pure perfection cinematic perfection and
I should be like so lucky to make
something so perfect one day I won't but
it takes a village and they got a small
village people and boy they coalesce
into something wonderful it hats off to
the riders to the directors to the
animators to the vocal talent to the
marketers for not forget for making me
pregnant but not like [ __ ] belly
bursting me by giving me too much
because there's so much in that movie
was an absolute surprise to me one of
the best days that I've had at the
movies in all of 2018 yeah and I can't
wait to go back you know you me - there
it is folks
Verve you probably longer than the movie
it so much we loved spider-man into the
spider-verse
indeed that's a fat man I'm Batman
Beyond now we'll get there we will I'm
Kevin Smith hi I'm Mark Barnard - and
then next time same bat time same bat
Channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
this has been a production of Smaug Co
internet radio sir
only at SModcast calm